بينما ننظر في التوقعات الاقتصادية للعام الجديد ،
يبدو أن قطاع السياحة قد
عاد إلى مساره الصحيح ،
ويقول مجلس السفر والسياحة العالمي أن
السفر قد يعود إلى
مستويات ما قبل الوباء هذا العام ، فماذا
يعني هذا بالنسبة للمنطقة وفقًا
لـ
كان من المتوقع أن يكون نمو الناتج المحلي الإجمالي الأخير للسياحة والسفر أكثر
من الضعف في الشرق الأوسط في عام 2022
مع زيادة 80 في الإنفاق من
الزوار الدوليين مقارنة بالعام
السابق لهذه الطفرة لن يكون فقط
نتيجة للوجهات الأكثر شعبية في المنطقة
ولكن  أيضًا بعض
اللاعبين الصاعدين بالطبع ، لقد أنشأت
مراكز سياحية في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط وشمال
إفريقيا ، يتبادر
إلى الذهن على الفور الأردن والمغرب وتعرف هذه البلدان
كيفية القيام بالسياحة ، وسأتطلع إلى ما
وراء هذه المراكز السياحية الراسخة
نحو العديد من المشاريع والمبادرات المتعلقة بالسياحة التي
تتخذ  مكان في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
ولا سيما المملكة العربية السعودية التي
لا تزال وفقًا لشركة WTCC ، كانت المملكة
ثالث أكبر مستثمر في هذا القطاع في
جميع أنحاء العالم في عام 2021 حيث تم ضخ ما يقرب من 37 مليار
دولار في السفر والسياحة في
ذلك العام من خلال استراتيجية حكومية
تُعرف باسم رؤية 2030 تهدف إلى جذب
100 مليون  الزائرون الدوليون بحلول عام
2030. قد يكون لهذا أيضًا تأثير
خارج حدودها ، أي تطورات
في المملكة العربية السعودية قادرة على جذب
المزيد من السياحة المحلية لجذب المزيد من
السعوديين إلى العروض المحلية بدلاً من
مغادرة السعوديين للبلاد ، وهذا
بالطبع سيؤثر على دول مثل
البحرين: التأثير الكبير الآخر الذي سيحدثه
التطور الكبير للمملكة العربية السعودية
ودفعها الاقتصادي في صناعة السياحة
هو على
مركز السياحة الخليجي المنشأ في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
وهم يتطلعون بالطبع إلى الاستمرار في
تحقيق المكاسب أيضًا والاستمرار في
البقاء.  تنافسي